If you want to hear how one forgotten scene
from the book makes a little easter egg appearance
in this movie then stick around to the end
of this video.
This video is sponsored by Raycon.
[Intro]
Welcome to Things You Missed, today we continue
the Carriethon...
Yeah, I'm calling it that now, with yet another
remake of Carrie, but this one, while not
as subliminal as the original, is actually
pretty good.
It makes some improvements and has some of
its own secrets.
So why don't we explore them?
[Things You Missed]
The volleyball game from the novel has been
changed to pool volleyball for the remake.
I think it makes a lot of sense, because of
the maturity of the female body is a major
theme in Carrie, and the swimsuits are just going
to highlight that.
Also, putting them in a pool gives more of
a reason for the shower scene to exist in
order to wash off that chlorine, since in this
time period, most kids would just slap on
some deodorant after a regular gym class.
Ms. Desjardin, basically looked like
Misty from Pokèmon in this scene.
Misty is a water type trainer and the gym
leader of the Cerulean City gym, while Ms.
D trains her students in water, and is the
gym teacher of the Ewen High School Gym.
Misty is known for nurturing the awkward,
misunderstood Psyduck, and Ms. D forms a special
bond with Carrie White.
When Carrie gets her first period in the shower
after class, I noticed this sign in the locker
room, which could foreshadow something that
happens in the prom scene where the twins
slip and fall on the wet floor.
I think there's a similar foreshadowing going
on with these umbrellas in Sue Snell's house
to setup the sprinklers at prom and when Carrie
uses her mind to break the locker room mirror
which sets up this part and this part.
Lately, we've seen a number a Stephen King's
novels get adapted for a second time, like
Pet Sematary and IT, but this movie seems
to want us to know that's it's just as much
of a remake of Brian DePalma's 1976 film than
it is a re-adaptation of the novel.
The car that Billy Nolan drives looks the
same, the theme of the prom seems to once
again be "Love Among The Stars" as opposed
to "Springtime in Venice" from the novel,
Carrie's dress is pink (or at least it starts
out that way), Carrie’s mother is crucified,
and Sue Snell's nightmare at the end is re-imagined,
and this isn't something that's in the book at all.
Carrie after recording Carrie's meltdown in
the locker room, Chris Hargensen, who is so
narcissistic that she has a picture of herself,
uploads it to YouTube.
it actually kind of giving me anxiety that
the tags and description aren't properly filled
out.
The girls who bullied Carrie are forced to
run sprints, but the rules are a bit different
than in the original.
"That's up to all of you but anyone who stops running
is suspended.
And if you're suspended, you're not going to prom."
I kind of feel like that's not that effective,
because the girls who most guilty are pretty
fit, so continuing to run wouldn't really be that
big of a deal for them compared to the others.
Anyway, while this is going on, Carrie is
excused from gym, and picks up some books
from the library, one of which is called Telekinesis:
Analysis and Aftermath.
In the novel, the story is broken up by excerpts
from books, articles and interviews about
the Carrie White incident and about the telekinesis
phenomenon, and this is one of the many publications
quoted.
The poem Carrie reads from in English class
is an excerpt from John Milton's 1671 poem
"Samson Agonistes".
I think that's how you say it.
It too hints at the tragic ending of this
story with lines like “From restless thoughts,
that like a deadly swarm of hornets arm’d,”
which connects to the idea of Carrie’s thoughts
literally being deadly because she can destroy
things with her mind and “of both my Parents
all in flames ascended,” which ties into
her mother’s idea that Carrie was born out
of sin and of course the fiery ending of the
senior prom.
One of the things I mentioned at the beginning
is how there are some little improvements
in certain areas, like how we're really shown
the weight of Sue's decision to miss the prom
in this one -- the fact that she's been dreaming
of it since she was young, how she already
has a dress picked out and how everyone expects
her to be there.
There are also some creative uses of the Telekinesis,
like how Carrie uses it to flip the light
switch moments before her mother walks in,
using it to hold down the foot pedal on the
sewing machine without actually using her
foot, and perhaps the most lazy one I've ever
seen, using it to turn on the radio.
It's right there, Carrie.
It's literally right there.
So Sue asks her boyfriend Tommy Ross to take
Carrie to the prom.
As always.
But this time, rather than Tommy being a baseball
player, football phenom or track star, he
keeps up with the theme of this being set
in 2013 and plays LaCrosse.
Should have gone with ultimate.
However, Carrie's mother does not approve
of her attending the prom.
Let’s roll it.
“They’ll paw at you.
They find where that blood smell comes from.
He’s gonna take you, Carrie, in his car
out into the wilderness.
Out where it’s cold and where the roadhouses
are and the whiskey.”
In the novel, roadhouses and whiskey are one
of those things that come up again and again
as a symbol of evil in the eyes of Mrs. White.
For example, her father was killed in roadhouse,
her husband impregnated her with the smell
of roadhouse whiskey on his breath and at
the end of the book Carrie chases Chris Hargensen
and Billy Nolan to a roadhouse called the
Cavalier, which by the way is represented
by an easter egg in the movie.
"A bunch of people were going to the Cavalier
after".
The Cavalier is where Chris and Billy sleep
sometimes and where they devise the plan to
humiliate Carrie.
The movie also shows step one of that plan
going into action when Billy and his friends
go to the pig farm.
"Don't worry little piggy.
Uncle Jack is gonna bash your head right
in.
They just really couldn’t help themselves
in this franchise could they?
“I’m just gonna bash your brains in. I'm gonna bash em right the heck in!”
The day of the prom would soon arrive.
Carrie and Tommy hang with Tommy’s friend
George and his date Erika, who goes to a different
school called Dover.
It actually works well that she is from another
school because she has no reason to think
Carrie is weird at all.
That was me at prom.
The kid… from another school.
But if you ask me, Sue Snell is the real weird
one in this movie, her boyfriend is literally
the only conversation in her phone.
This, supposed Prom Queen favorite seriously
only talks to one person?
Come on.
If you pause the movie as the students are
filling out their votes for Prom King and
Queen, there are even more easter eggs and
other Things You Missed.
The Prom Scene in Carrie is often referred
to as The Black Prom.
I always find it strange how something so
tragic can sound so similar to something so
sweet… like Black Friday: the day where
you’re gonna be getting incredible deals
on Raycon earbuds using my link in the description.
Right now I’ve got a pair of Raycon earbuds.
I’ve been using these things all the time.
They’re already half the cost of other premium
wireless earbuds before my discount.
They’re comfortable, no annoying stems or
wires and they stay in your ear while while
you’re doing stuff.
Look at this.
*metal music*
What I love about them is that clean, isolated,
quality sound that they deliver straight to
your ears.
Plus, you don’t have to worry about battery
life.
The latest model lasts 6 hours, so you could
use them to watch all three Carrie movies
back to back if you wanted to.
Which I may have done.
With more bass, a compact design, great color
options and a charging case that extends the
battery life to 24 hours, there has never
been a better time to pick up some Raycons.
Great gift idea.
Just click the link in the description to
get early access to Raycon’s Black Friday
and Cyber Monday deals!
I can’t even tell you how good the deals
will be—you’ll have to check them out
on the website!
buyraycon.com/czworld
There's a lot more than what meets the eye on the prom King and Queen ballot.
First we got Frank Grier and Jessica Upshaw.
Frank was a football player in the book and
Jessica Upshaw is one of the bullies.
George Chizmar and Frieda Jason.
George was the most renowned artist at the
school who created murals displayed at the
prom and Frieda is his girlfriend.
These write ins are a joke, Morton and Desjardin.
Morton if you don’t remember is the assistant
principal, and Desjardin is the gym teacher,
so I imagine this ballot was filled by one
of the girls who was punished for bullying
Carrie White and still upset about Morton
and Desjardin teaming up to dish out the punishment.
Don Farnham and Helen Shyres.
Don’s only mention in the book is that he’s
dating Helen and Helen is another one of the
bullies.
After Tommy Ross and Carrie White, we’ve
got Brian Cranstone and Emma Tamblyn.
Brian, not to be confused with the dad from
Malcolm in the Middle is gets his name from
the on set carpenter of Carrie (he also worked
on It and It Chapter 2) and Emma worked the
in the costume department.
Not sure about Peter Nicolakakos, but Myra
Crewes is a minor character in the novel.
And finally: Jordan Samuel and Susan Reilly
Lehane.
Jordan was the head of the makeup department
and Susan was the makeup artist for Juliane
Moore.
This one might be the coolest looking blood
spill, although I don’t know if I can show
it, Carrie force chokes Ms Desjardin… hopefully
I can show that, and after destroying the
prom, returns home to face her mother.
Margret White’s only real hobby seems to
be sewing, so I found it kind of cool that
Carrie uses that against her by impaling her
with all her own tools.
Wait, where have I seen this before?
"Look at this! I took 9 million steps today!"
There’s nothing more terrifying than that.
Finally, Carrie uses her telekinesis to bring
down the entire house, but there’s
one small moment where we see what is actually
destroying it.
After lifting up her mother, a rock can be
seen punching through the ceiling and landing
on this dresser.
This is a reference to an event from the book
known as the Rain of Stones, which is documented
in a weekly magazine that tells of an incident
that took place when Carrie was a little girl.
Accounts from the Whites’ neighbors say
one day after Margret upset her, rocks started
to fall from the sky, but only above the White's
house, and pierce through the roof tiles while
Carrie was having a meltdown.
However, the story never really became mainstream
because by the time the media showed up, Mrs.
White had already had the roof repaired, but
all the neighbors swear by what happened.
The scene has only been adapted in the 2002
TV movie, where the stones look more like
meteors.
Apparently it was planned to be included in
both theatrical movies, but got cut both times,
other than this little easter egg.
So now the question becomes, do I do Carrie
2: The Rage, for a future episode of Things
You Missed?
Let me know in this poll.
And whatever you do decide, you're gonna want
to make sure you subscribe to CZsWorld for
new horrors every week, ring the deathbell
for notifications, use the link in the description
to buy Raycons, and I'll see you in the next
one.
Assuming we both survive.